[音楽]
anitta エロ
みなさんこんにちはー
はーい
各位の男が出てきました
a
僕は誰でしょう
ございます
医者です
医者が出てきたってことですねあの新しい治療法だったり新しい健康法だったり
そんな
いい話が聞けるんじゃないかなと
思えかなと思いますでも今日は僕はそういう話は
残念ながらしません
じゃあ何を話すか
実は
これです
おかしいですよねうん
医者が医療崩壊すべてどうすんだと
僕も思います僕も本当は医療崩壊をすすめたいわけではありません
じゃあなんでこんなことを僕は言ってるか
実はですね僕はへ
医者になる前経済学部を卒業しています
で
1から
医学部に入り直して
卒業して一緒になりました
もちろん経済も良かったんですけどなんか直接
人の役に立てる仕事って
なんかないかなーと思って一緒になりました
で
医師免許取って
僕は内科医なので
大きな病院でですね胃カメラしたり
そういうことをしましたそうするとですね
他の病院の先生病院の中のほかの先生から
うちの患者さん
ごはん食べられなくなったから
先生色あのい camera できるから色を入れてくれないか
そんな話がよく来るようになりました色っていうのですね皆さんご存知かもしれないん
ですけどもこうやってお腹にあらを開けて
直接胃に多くそういう栄養方です
僕もですね
最初は全然うまくできなかったんですけど
南レイも何でもやっているうちにだんだん上手にあってい
他の先生からもなくなったねうんかですね
上手になったねとか言われて得意になってた時期がありました
そんな時に
近くのですね高齢者施設
に入ったら
すごくショックだったございました
それは
道東
ほとんどの
病棟にいる患者さんがほとんど寝たきりで移動されていた
そして
その患者さんほとんど意識がない
寝たきりで意識がなくて
会話もできない
痛いも痒いも言えない
その状態で何年も長い人は10年以上です
その状態を見た時に僕は本当にショックを受けました
石を辞めようかなと思いました
人の役に立とうと思って医者になった
それなのにまったく人の役に立っているという実感が沸かなかった
会社を辞めようとも思いながら悩んでいましたその時
ちょうどですね北海道の夕張市で床が財政破綻して
医療崩壊して
そこで頑張っている先生村上先生という人が予防医療とかですねそういうの頑張って
いるということでええ
救いを求めてですね
縁に行きました
で今日はそんな話をしようかなと思っております
us 皆さん
ご存知ですか
北海道の
まぁだいたいマンなかったですねここにあります
札幌がここなので
北海道の中ではかなり近い方なんですけど
でもこれでもですね60機があります
60キロというと鹿児島で言えばですねだいたい錦江湾一つ丸々入るくらい
くらいの距離ですね
意外と遠いですねそういったね
夕張と言えばみなさん
ねっ
メロンですねそのといっ
メロンそしてさっき言った
大仙波ターンこの2ついうのですねでも
実はですね
一番大事なものがあります
これ日本一なんですけどこれ有名じゃないでも一番大事だと思います
何でしょう実は
高齢化率
高齢化率が45%です
日本一です
今日本がですね日本全体が25%
ならほど場合ですね
これだけ高齢者が多い日本一高齢者が多い所で
普通に考えたらですよ
医療は充実してくれなきゃいけない
って考えますよねでもさっき言った米医療崩壊してしまった
ねぇ
医療崩壊一言で言いますけど具体的にはこういうことです
それまではですね夕張市内に総合病院が一つあって170一緒
それが医療崩壊財政破綻によって氏がお金ものを出せないよ
市立病院は継続できませんということで小さな診療所
19社になりました病床はほぼ10分の1ですね
もちろん
医者もされました
医療機器もですねなんと今は
夕張市内に ct mri
1台もない0台です
しないですよ病院じゃなくて
ねっ
しかも救急病院もなくなった
90秒がなくなるということはこういうことです
救急車が病院まで到着する時間それまで30分台だったんだけど
なんとほぼ2倍60分後になりました
もちろん
ちょっとした風邪とかねそういう発熱ぐらいだったら
市内の診療所で僕らが見ます
ただ例えば心筋梗塞例えば交通事故で大怪我したからね
そうなったとき
札幌の病院までドクターヘリで行ってもらいます
となると必然的に
時間は延びますよね
じゃあ
この状況で夕張市民
生活できる思いますか不安でしょうがないですよ
でも
僕が入ってみたら夕張シーンがすごく元気でした
どういうことか
例えばこの人
お若く見えますけど実はですね
60代です
60代の女性
もうすぐお孫さん中学生
すごいですよね
この人ですね a 診療所の近くで床屋さんがやってて
街の中心人物ですね
よなようなこの人の家で飲み会が開催されるというね
もちろん僕も参加する
でそこでどんな話がされるかというとですね
今日はダンプ歩いた何万パールいたーーー
今日は雪かきを何時間した
血圧は今だけ今下がってるぞ
花ですね私は元を
早期発見して治療したと
はですねそういう
いい話ばっかり聞くんですねー
でこの人は何をやっているかと言うとですね先ほどからちょっと不思議に思っていると
思いますけど
私は病院は絶対行かない
医者は嫌いだって言うんですねこの人
でまぁもちろん大きな病気とか
怪我とかですね大きな計画と化した時は医者の便りを者さんところけれどもそれまでは
私はできるだけ自分の
名機力を
頼りに
ネキルコあげるそのためにストレッチをやるんだって言って座布団こうやってね
押し上げてストレッチをしてくれている姿はこれですね
そこ僕が激写したという
ええええええ
でもですよ
ct も mri も医療機器もすべての医療機器
道具です健康で長生きするための道具ですよね
もしそれがなくても健康が保たれるのであればそれは非常に素晴らしいことです
近くに病院が総合病院があるということよりも
市民が意識を変えるということは
ミュウがあること以上に価値があることだと僕は思います
50代60代元気な人まあいいでしょう
じゃあ
80代90代の爺ちゃん婆ちゃ
さすがに病院がなかったら不安でしょうがないんじゃないかと
ね思いませんかね思いますよねはい
この方90代の女性ばあちゃんですね
この方を
まだお元気なこの曲心
この人ですね
診療所で肺に影が見つかって札幌の病院で検査しました
したら ct とか色々検査したら肺がんが見つかったんですね
肺がんが見つかったら普通は
抗がん剤をやるやるとかですね入院して治療しましょう
端になります
もちろんそういう話をされたそうですが
このバージョンですねなんとその1回さっぽろに行って検査したきり二度と行かなかっ
たん
いう場に帰って最後まで生活しました
その亡くなる直前の写真がこれ
すごくいい映像ですよね
亡くなる前の日の晩まででまんじゅう立つ
好きな物を食べて
ご家族に囲まれて地域の人々に囲まれながら最後まで
生活することをこの人は選んだと
いうことですね
で
こんなことをしてからですねこういう高齢者がいっぱいいるようです
よくよく考えたら僕が総合病院時代に感じていたこと
色の方がいっぱいいるような世界
夕張ではですね
そういう高齢者は生き生きとしてない高齢者が一人もいませんでした
だこれは僕の印象です
こうだなんかすごい世界が広がってるなぁと思ってますけど
実はですね印象だけじゃなくて数字にもれました
例えばこれです
救急車の出動回数
下がっちゃったんですねちゃんに全国的にはこの10年でほぼ1.5倍
高齢化率が高まれば高まるほど
救急車の紹介数がどんどんヘ
普通に考えたらそうだと思いますでも
高齢化率日本一の夕張市高齢化率
下がってんじゃないけどまだまだがあったんですよ2年3年前は43%でした
今45%まだまで上がっているでもなんとですねこうなっちゃうんです
昆布半分ですね
救急車が呼ばれなくなったどういうことか
さっきのばあちゃんキュ記者ようがないんです
なんでか
だって
もう命を
命の終わりを受け入れているんですね
救急車というのは子の命を助けてくれという叫びのもとに呼ばれるものですよね
あのバージョンは助けてくれると思ってないんです最後まで自分の家で生活したいと
思ったんです
だからよくのは訪問看護師在宅医
もちろん発熱とかですね一時的なことで
まあこれは良くなるよということであれば家で点滴したり
細工使ったですね治療します
でもそうでない時は残念ながらを見たりすると
そういう世界です
だから救急じゃないしかもですねー
いよう費も減っちゃったんですね高齢者1人当たり医療費
全国的には
ものすごいキャラれています
夕張市は何か一時より
だいぶ下がった
すごいですよねぇー
多分救急車が減るとか高齢者の医療費が減るとかそういう地域って全国でもほとんど
無いと思います
でも夕張車で来たしかもですね
なんと
絞りつまり下がっちゃったんですよ
これがすごいです
日本人の死因の1位がちゃんにーが肺炎
じゃあコニーが心臓ですねで3位が肺炎
わんつーすに全部食べちゃった
すごいですよ
何がポイントかたぶん僕はもうに
予防の意識ですね市民が予防のほうに意識を変える
病院があるから安心ではなくてしっかり自分でできることはやるんだぞ
予防の意識
日本人の病気の
大部分は生活習慣病から起きているといいます
だったら生活習慣を変えればいいじゃないですか
みんなわかってるけどできない
ね
あともう一つ
終末期医療
残念ながら日本人の
死亡率は100%を
ね日本人だけじゃないですけどね
何医療が解決できない問題がやってきます
その時にしっかりと終末期にイメージを持っているか持ってないか
家族と話し合っているか話し合ってないか地域の人たちとそういう話をしているか
もうもちろんですね文書にまとめてばいっすよリビングウィルとかですね
そこまでなくても地域で話をしている家族で話をしているとその事実があるだけでも
結果は全然違うと思います
さらに
地域社会ですね
若い時は予防の意識を高める地域にみんなで予防の意識を高め
年を取ってきたらみんなで地域みんなでその命を受け止める
そういう温かい地域社会をつくる
これがポイントだと思います
じゃあですねこれ
尿しみだからできたんでしょうよく言われるんです
夕張は財政破綻したから
夕張市民だからできたんでちょっと鼻で笑われることがあります
一緒にするなと
でも
確かにですよ
夕張市民は危機感があったからできた
かもしれないじゃあ僕らは日本人
危機感持たなくていいのか僕は危機感を持った方がいいと思います
なぜならば今国全体の借金は1200腸炎と言われていますね
中央政府と地方自治体の借金はしたら戦略醤油
これを1人当たりにすると1人1000万円
ね皆さん1000万剤を抱えています
ただ
今生まれたばかりの赤ん坊と90代の爺ちゃん婆ちゃん比べたらやっぱり
そこは赤ん坊はこれから長く返していかなきゃいけない
さがありますよね
となると今生まれてきた嵌合は生まれた瞬間になんとですね
8000300万円の借金を背負った状態で生まれてくるという計算する先生もいます
しかもですよこれは現時点の数字ですこれから高齢化率はどんどん
ね今日本がここです25%
数十年後には40%であります
じゃあ高齢化率が2倍になったら
借金も2倍になるんですか
イオンやどんどん上がっていますよね
ちなみに優雅には今ココです
かなり先取りしますねー
でも日本中が何夕張みたいに高齢化率が高くなる
じいちゃんばあちゃんばっかりになる
その世界になります
しかもですよこれから人口はどんどん
えるらしいです
今までの100年は異常な100年でした
それまでずーっと寝1000万20003000マンでほぼ横ばいだったのに
この100年でなんと1億2000万円だった
これから
こうなるらしいです
よくて半分悪いとサムの千代ムチ
今までの意識で今後の100年を乗り切れるという保証はないですね
意識を変えなきゃいけない
病院が欲しいなに何が欲しいあれも欲しいこれも欲しいという時代から病院がなくても
やっていけるよっていうような時代になっていくべきじゃないかなと思います
じゃあですね日本もう未来はないのか
そんなことはないと思います
これ見てください
日本はですね高齢化にずっと世界一なんですこれからも
日本だけじゃないですよ世界中が高齢化率がどんどん上がっていく
さらにこれエコノミストという雑誌の表紙ですけど
日の丸に押しつぶされていますこんなショッキングなことされあの
特集されるのも日本が注目されているのです
世界中が解決できない高齢化問題日本はその世界一なんです
日本世界中が注目しています
だからこんなことを言われるんですね
じゃあどうするか
これが医療費ですけど世界10位はどんどん上がっています
アメリカフランスからだイギリス
これからも高齢化率はどんどん高くなる多分こうなるでしょう
じゃあ
どうするか夕張はこうなったんです下げられた
じゃあ日本も夕張の真似すればいいんじゃないですか
さあこうなるねもしこうなったら世界中がビックリしますよね世界中から尊敬される
高齢化者対策をできる日本に慣れると思います
これ僕は夕張モデルと言ってますけどこれから日本モデルにしなきゃいけないなと思っ
ています
そんな思いで僕は九州に帰ってきました
2007年夕張市が財政破綻した時
井原市民どうなっちゃうんだろう可哀想だなと思いませんでしただ
僕は九州で思ってました
でももしかしたら今かわいそうなのは僕らかもしれない
夕張市実はわかった
でも僕らはもしかしたら気づいてない
もしかしたら気づいてないフリをしているだけかもしれん
日本が
世界のリーダーになれる
鹿児島はですね明治時代に日本を
変えた
実績を持っています
鹿児島がかよく変われば日本が変わる
日本が変われば世界が変わると僕は勝手に思っています
なんかこう考えるとワクワクしますよね
軍事力でもなく政治力でもなく経済力でもなく高齢化対策で日本は世界のリーダーに
なれる
そんなことを僕は考えています
一緒にワクワクしながら世界を変えてみませんか
ご静聴ありがとうございます
[拍手]
[音楽]
いいします
ha
th